[Music]
[Applause]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake I'm
really excited to be talking about equal
economic opportunity and freedom around
the world especially in Africa we have
maguet way joining us thank you for
coming on to the show thanks for having
me Ellen I really appreciate it thank
you thank you thank you you you are a
huge role model to me in multitude of
ways and I am so inspired by watching
your content so inspired by watching the
way that you are just carry yourself
with increasing the um the degrees of
freedom for young people especially in
Africa it's just it warms me it warms my
heart and I love it I love it so can we
start by talking about you and your
story and how you got started with
caring so much about this well I was
born in Senegal for west coast of Africa
and then my family moved to Germany and
then to France but I will never forget
when I was about to leave for Germany my
grandma said to me you're about to go to
this place where most people will not
look like you they'll have a different
skin color and most of them will speak a
different language than the one you
speak and most also the children there
would have where they have been going to
school and you have not yet been going
to school because I had decided I just
didn't want to go to school when I was a
kid but she said but I don't want for
any of that to intimidate you and her
words were very well chosen she said
none of that shouldn't be intimidate you
you can be impressed if you want but no
intimidation and she said because at the
end of the day the difference between
scholar is still a color of skin of
humans and their humans and use and
you're human and that language which was
speaking is still a language what humans
speak and you're a human being so you
should be able to speak the same thing
as four of them going to school you
don't know what it is like but you'll
learn you're going to school is what
little humans do and you're a little
human so you will be just fine and so I
went I went to Germany and everything
she had said have turned out to be true
so when it is such a young age you get
the proof of you know whatever it is
that you were told it just makes you
believe so I believe grandma because
what she said was there but predictions
were better and so sure enough what
comes next should be true which is and
so what take it easy
have faith in yourself and get going and
you will you will get to speak that
language you will get to understand what
school is and do it just perfectly well
and and that's exactly what I did and of
course it worked out very well for me
so that's in my early years and then at
some point the family decided to move to
France we moved to France and after
business school in France I decided that
France would be too small for my
ambitions so I left France but one thing
that we're starting to hear that French
people I know right well they all know
your ambition have to be you know at the
end of the day it's all about belief in
oneself I really do believe in myself
but it's the biggest gift but my grandma
and my father have given me to this
ability to believe in myself love it
yeah shout and shout out to grandma and
absolutely
oh no I that's the greatest of gifts
they give me a long ears with the love
but so but while I was in Europe as soon
as I got to Europe actually question
started to pop in my head it was not so
much a question it was just like an
observation at first and the
observationally led to a question and it
was this is odd
I came from his place in Africa now I'm
over here but two places obviously did
not enjoy the same level of prosperity
economic prosperity yeah prosperity it's
just worse in my face it was in my face
and as a little being I was just like
what's the deal here what's the deal so
it was just the seed was planted and
that seed never left me because as a
very curious child I was always like
what's going on and why is it this way
and so when you ask me where where where
did what I'm doing today come from it
came from that simple observation from a
little seven-year-old girl who is just
like I don't understand why where it
came from where I came from we don't
have running water like enough coming
out of a faucet normally and here it is
here and here everybody seems to have a
car everything you know life's feels
just so much easier from some certain
standpoint of course there's a lot of
things I love for my for my for my you
know native Senegal but you know why do
why do things look like this in in
Senegal yeah and why do things look like
Europe yeah in Europe yes
beyond just you know the the
architecture or anything like that I'm
talking about life yes no running water
electricity yes things like that basics
I'm talking about basics and their
abundance and accessibility and
interestingly enough these basics
running water access to food shelter
health care education electricity etc
they're the things that enable one to
maximally flourish into the world and
those degrees of freedom are limited
than our soul gets limited in right
exactly exactly
why is it that in this place people will
spend most of their days women spend
hours walking to go fetch water and
hours to come back hours same thing to
go look for dead wood to cook or
whatever not that my family directly was
affected by that but I would have been
blind or from a different country if I
told you that I didn't see those things
and I'm I'm as afro optimist as they are
for the longest time I did not want to
even talk about these things or talk
about these but you know the images are
everywhere and I don't want them to be
the only story about Africa but the
truth is that's what struck me how come
here I don't see anybody walking miles
and miles and miles a day every single
day to go fetch water and or you know
any of these things I was just like why
what's going on over here why is it like
you just flip over here you just miss
electricity it was just weird strange I
didn't have flow is very missed I'm an
optimist yeah we all should be yes yes
yes I'm a radical optimist radical
optimist yeah but also
realist with knowing that what we need
to do to get the right things in place
that's why I'm a radical optimist I'm
because my optimism is backed by my
understanding and my rational
understanding of how the human mind and
spirit works and also how economics
works and that if you truly do liberate
the human spirit and the human person if
you give them the freedoms humans will
always dazzle you that much I know
so I'm not a radical optimist in a
vacuum I'm a radical optimist because I
know that given the chance to manifest
their potential given the freedom to
manifest their potential man as in
humans will do amazing things yes yes
okay so you now you're seeing this
dichotomy between Europe and Africa and
you're now starting to question what is
going on and you see that it is these
degrees of freedom that is holding back
the the economic prosperity actually you
were you were teaching me about this I
thought this was crazy it was the when
I was learning from you it was the the
World Bank Doing Business Index ranks
the 54 African countries amongst some of
the lowest in the world yeah for the for
the frictionless enos of doing business
that's right
and so when you have to pay these 45%
tariffs on importing materials that you
need to run a business and when you have
to deal with potential greed and
corruption of coming in and saying you
didn't do your numbers right on your
accounting and that that means that we
can now hold things over your head it
just it's holding people back exactly
mint is the future a frictionless that's
right so basically so to go from being
this little seven-year-old girl just
watching this world she just came from
this place now is in this place and
what's going on to today what I know it
was a journey it was really a journey so
for the longest time I you know I took
it that maybe it's because you know you
have a common explanation of why the
disparity between the two places some
people would say it's because there was
colonialism before because there was
slavery before because there was this
because there was that I am NOT saying
that any of that stuff did not is not
part of you know the problem as to why
we are where we are today I'm not saying
it doesn't play a role in it but I don't
but what really to me ruined the whole
experience was in terms of or some
people telling you oh you know people go
all over the place with this when they
see Africa poor countries the rest of
the world not and then they go into just
look at any any article talking about
poverty in Africa or anything like that
or any issue in Africa look at the
comments I usually tend not to do it but
once in a while I go there and it is
dispiriting people thinking that the
reason why Africans are poor is because
well low IQ people these idiots no
seriously you read stuff like that and
there is obviously the IQ fury you know
out there of blacks being at the bottom
of a total
when it comes to you know intelligence
so some people think it's because that's
a reason probably why we can't amount to
much more than we are today where others
are gonna tell you oh it's because of
you know these savages they're just busy
hacking each other all the time I mean
what can you expect from people like
that and others it's just like well you
know they're hungry overseas or we don't
have access to clean water it's all over
the place when it comes to the reasons
why Africa is where it is compared to
which should be and could have been it's
the reasons that people advance are all
over the place except but none of them
made sense to me and on that one I also
go to those reasons kind of almost more
or less match the sustainable
development goals of a meal of the UN
you know the SDGs there we have 17 goals
basically and what was surprising to me
is they say oh poverty is one of the
goals two of the things to fight and
then there's malnutrition and then there
is access to clean water there is all of
these things but I challenge you go back
and take a look at the 17 goals and you
tell me the degree of separation between
that one goal and poverty as a root
cause poverty is the root cause of
almost the rest of the whole entire
exactly exactly exactly that is a and
the fact that the SDG is separating this
huge it's just like it's everywhere you
look there's to be a problem but in the
end whatever and then they separate
poverty from you know poverty is one of
it's almost poverty somebody must stand
on its own all of these other issues
stand on their own I'm like no you don't
understand who is malnourished
traditionally somebody who does not have
enough money to buy food who needs help
with access to clean water yes somebody
who didn't have a means to access clean
water I'm telling you in Nigeria a
wealthy people get their water
shipped on private jets you know from
the West in no time
so when you have money you you can get
stuff best never a problem of person was
who has money so the fact that we are
just not understanding so all of us are
running around tackling these different
issues they have this idea of why Africa
is poor I got confused by all of us when
I was younger because me too I didn't
know where to turn because everywhere
everybody has an idea as to why we're
where we are so and so like I said were
because we don't have access to pure
water
we don't have ax some people are even we
don't have access to clean shoe two
shoes if only you gave me shoes TOMS
shoes oh the poverty is gonna go away
you know like we're we're fixing poverty
one shoe at a time Willy so anyway none
of accept but none of this made so much
sense to me because even when you're
telling me about education how many
people do we have at ourselves made men
and women people who did not really have
access to education and by the way today
my country Senegal that how many PhDs do
you have walking in the streets of that
car with no job we have such a
population over educated I don't know if
it's such a finger already kitted but
what I mean by that is tremendously
well-educated people who are still
walking around with no jobs because I
don't care how many diplomas you have if
a job is not there for you to get in
forget it on you know so and then the
other thing was to me was okay why is
this country well you know prosperous
and mine is not and they also want to
make me think it has something to do
with me but I'm like I don't understand
and then that thing does not stand
because if it was me somehow who has a
problem with my IQ or whatever how come
that the minute my parents immigrated
from Senegal to the West their potential
their earning potential increases
dramatically yeah when I compared the
earnings that my parents get to have
with the ones that their brothers and
sisters get to have when they're staying
home it's their night
why so all of a sudden I've got my proof
there but there's something else
probably at play here that doesn't have
anything to do with all the stuff that
I'm hearing people talk about so all of
the stuff that I'm saying
so between the fact that I'm seeing that
one human being depending on where they
get to live have access to a completely
different outcome that was trench and
the fact that when someone comes to me
and say oh your country is poor because
you have malnutrition you have this you
have that but I'm like that also doesn't
make so much sense to me it's not okay
we need to stay on that point that was
such a profound point that depending on
where you're born you have different
degrees of freedom different access to
opportunity that needs to be solved as
soon as possible to where everyone has
an equal baseline of their ability to
pursue with freedom whatever they desire
in their life exactly so the link with
that with what you just said here the
link there between again and again I go
back to where I was which is okay that's
not the person yet here in this place
people seem to enjoy people seem to be
able to to flourish more in terms of
what they're able to accomplish and in
this place in this other place over
there it seems like that's kind of its
kind of cut at the root almost I thought
when I started thinking at the end of
the day we're talking about poverty
versus prosperity I wouldn't know what
exactly is poverty I actually what is
poverty right and so when I started
thinking about a lot of adam' like okay
you're poor when you have no money to
buy to cater to your basic needs you
have no money because you have no source
of income a source of income for most of
us is a job isn't it where do jobs come
from so you see this it all started for
me from that idea of what is poverty and
the lack of the poverties lack of money
lack of money because lack of source of
income our source of income for most of
us being a job where do jobs come from
they come from businesses mainly small
and medium-sized businesses so wow
that's interesting and then if you tell
of the way you think you you got you
followed do gotta follow I gotta follow
a trail you got a 12-2
to the deepest level of a root because
otherwise you're only dealing with
symptoms and that's what we're doing
today most of us are including the UN
but you when people are dealing with
through with symptoms when you're trying
to bring me clean water you're dealing
with
a symptom of poverty easier if a
consequence of poverty if you if you
want yeah and if you want a sustainable
solution to my lack of access to clean
water or you know nutritious foods or
whatever it is maybe go and deal with
the root of a problem which is poverty
and then you'll see all these balloons
start to pop up in the air gone the
problem is great a lot of these will be
done
so anyway I'm just like um so when I
discovered that I'm like jobs Wow jobs
comes from businesses now then don't you
think that we should think about the
environment and the climate then for
businesses yeah especially given that I
started doing business went back home in
Africa when all these things started to
pop - really now start to really
materialize in my head because again
this is a question that has followed me
for now by then it was a couple decades
right and that was t that was - your son
right
that was Edina that was a dinner okay
yeah so by that time by that time I've
been couple decades of me being tortured
by this question of why is my country
where are some countries poor and others
rich and you were bringing your brings
senegalese recipes and ingredients to US
markets in skincare and beverages yeah
beverages but so beverage was the first
one Edina Edina so Edina traditional
beverage for my country
hibiscus drinks ginger drink sweet
things like that it was a really good
healthy drinks for you yeah so as I was
doing that and with this question and
this realization that I and this linkage
shift I had made in my mind between
poverty and jobs and businesses and
looking at how much I was struggling to
get my businesses going and the supply
chain going in Africa I started when
being like why Wow
why is it so hard to do business in this
country and then I started looking
and then I was started being interested
in okay is it just me or what I'm seeing
is really true because you see my
businesses we had two sister companies
one in Senegal one in the US because the
u.s. is the market and Senegal is where
everything gets you know gets imported
from so I'm comparing the two why is it
in the US you get to start an LLC within
twenty minutes depending on how fast you
type it cost you you know twenty dollars
for our registration and you know couple
hundred dollars for you know there's
another part of that but the rocket
speed yes yes least friction yeah and
then also so if s all it costs twenty
minutes of your time because if you just
a couple hundred dollars compared that
to back then in Senegal it could it
could it could take you up to a year of
your of your time to take to get to try
and register business legally and with
also the cost is almost a year's worth
of salary back in the days so I was like
okay this is kind of strange let me see
if this is an anecdote meaning it's just
my in my case is how it happened or is
there something more more systemic to
this and that's when I started and as I
started looking into this I that's when
I learned but there are such things such
indexes that we're measuring how easy or
hard it was to start and run a business
in any country in the world that's right
and the two ones that I really put my my
attention on one is the doing business
of a World Bank which measures ten
indicators all of them having to do with
again how hard or easy it is to start
and run a business anywhere from legally
registering your business to the permits
to including also having access to
electricity or not to what do you call
it to the labor laws to how easy or hard
it is to file your taxes pay your taxes
all of that and also the fraser economic
institute the academic freedom the
Fraser Institute academic freedom Index
as well so those to systematically show
that most African countries are
basically at the bottom of the list
so there's strong correlation between
right there again between how easy or
hard it is it will be to do business in
the country and the economic freedom of
the country and whether or not that
country's rich or poor yes yes I'm so
happy that you got directly you also you
got to the route and also what's very
interesting is I think this is the first
time on the show that when we're
discussing the SDGs that it's all of the
attention is on poverty all of it - the
first one - poverty because then the
other SDGs almost all of them in terms
of the individual basic necessities that
people need go away when poverty's
addressed and poverty is addressed with
money which is addressed of jobs which
is addressed or businesses and so this
is happening all around the world there
are amazing women as well like Roya
maboob as well is doing amazing work as
well as if Gani entrepreneurs and and
young and again young women empowering
them to have jobs which then they have
financing which then enables them to
have better careers for their kids as
well better schooling better job
opportunities
it's sad your flourishing in their in
their local countries so you see you
interestingly when you went from the
from Edina
to Tia Santos on and now skinny scan
skin of skin so so tell us about skinny
skin because 50% of profits go to
organizations that end bias and decrease
racial discrimination got it which is
extremely important yeah so please teach
us about this yeah and if you if you
allow me to go just back because there's
something I wanted to run the talk you
remember when you were talking about you
like the SDGs you know they differ it's
17 goals but poverty is really the one
the main one that they really should be
focusing on because that one could take
care of many more of the other goals the
one of the problem I have even there so
you see one of the issues we have today
Alan is I do feel but there is a bias
against free markets
and insofar as free markets is really a
key solution in this problem I find it
highly highly and more immoral yeah this
bias talking about bias but we have but
the mainstream has against free market I
do not forgive a mainstream for the bias
that they have because this is where we
have moral urgency right now
I mean markets are a major key to
economic it's a major free markets and
economic freedom is essential it's at
the heart of what needs to happen yet
despite that they're under it is it is
it is heartbreaking heartbreaking from
the people who position themselves as
those who care to give it such lip
service it's heartbreaking so that's one
of my message here because we have been
wasting so much time and people are
dying as I'm speaking to you right now
some young kids are making the decision
right now to probably get themselves
into little fisherman's boats and
they're gonna try to cross over to
Europe to find a job and that boat will
not make it you I don't know if you've
been hearing about it Aquarius all of us
boater your numbers as high as 1500 Oh
in a village in this one village 1500
it's a one village where you almost have
no more young boys young guys they're at
the bottom of the ocean serving as fish
food here's one of the images of people
stockpiling onto boats trying to cross
the sea yes I'm for economics yes
prosperity yes and rather than again
solving the root cause of poverty across
the world in these different areas right
provide right people with their
appreciation yeah I know this is lots of
people dying and is not okay yeah so not
only people are dying but then think
about it push push push for thinking not
only are people dying those who'd ever
make it or dying but then the ones who
make it who are they these are the
migrants you hear about and I'm gonna
talk only about the economic migrants
because the people who come in from
Syria and other places like that those
are more like you know war refugees and
things end up
you know people were coming because of
those causes that's slightly different
but I'm talking about economic migrants
and also think about it a lot of people
coming to the United States especially
from Latin American countries a lot of
them are economic migrants that's right
and because and now think about it where
we stand right now in 2018 I will not
teach you that we have a rise of
populism
all over the world Europe is feeling and
saying that they're just you know Angela
Merkel is you so what happened to her
she basically got caught out she
basically the whole migrant thing got
caught up caught up with her and the
Wrights extreme right out rights are
rising all over europe italy austria
everywhere it is happening now and we're
the world is about to have a very new
new face a new dynamic and led by hate
and fear why because a lot of them are
worried and not accepting of these
migrants coming to their shores in the
united states we have something similar
going on so i hear the world talking
about a migration problem but very
little
do I hear and I hear them the furthest
they would go is oh yeah we have these
migrants yeah economic migrants yeah
because we don't have any jobs push it
push it forever what's the solution what
do we do yeah what do we do beyond one
side telling the other but they're
jackasses because you know they don't
want to let the poor and destitute in
while the other side is telling the
other side also you guys are jackasses
too because you want to accept all the
misery of a world in our shores you see
they're just out there pointing pointing
but no one is thinking but in the middle
of this you know you have these people
is the economic prosperity yeah who
given a choice would have stayed home
yeah we want to stay give it a choice
most people want to stay home and raise
their families in dignity in peace
that's what everybody wants most of
these people in the first place did not
want to come there coming just because
that's the only way to feed my families
back home in in peace and decency right
so is any of these people thinking what
can we what should be done
to help that happen in their countries
well when you see when all of a sudden
that you know there's this bias against
the free markets then all of a sudden I
have all of these people who supposedly
care who are not advocating for more
economic freedom to happen in their
countries and that's the tragedy of
today
that's our twentieth today so it's not
just people dying at at sea and along
the road some of my people also get sold
as slaves in Libya when you go through
the land route so it's not just that so
you get slope that you get sold as a
slave or you die and then when you get
to this other country they hate your
guts they are you know a prejudiced
against you and so populism is rising so
even the face of a world is changing as
we know it with the dynamics of
political political dynamics you see
what's going to us but what would happen
if we actually promoted more economic
freedom in all of these countries more
people being able to stay home less
maybe populism happening and people
framing better everywhere that's right
and let's talk about your solution
because this is your solution exactly
it's a skin is skin is one of your
solutions and you hope to have more and
more young entrepreneurs caring about
getting economic freedom degrees effect
into the poverty areas of the world -
yes the reason they're so so skinny skin
so please teach us now about this
because you have these Minh you know in
your and I really want people to go and
watch you know the video links are in
the bio everyone the video link for how
we thrive made in may is from the it was
it was a it's a really really strong
video um
meh a is a city of like 23,000 people
roughly um and that's north of do cars
yes couple hours a couple hours north
and it's it's a it's a again the it's
right here on you know go check it out
the links in the bio please go watch it
it's such a profoundly awareness
shifting video and that was a really
amazing feature and so okay so please
teach us about schema scene because in
that video there is this I love seeing
the expressions of the the names the
names it was oh
Ibraheim oh yeah we remand or um he cuz
he went from his and this is I'm serious
when you have the empathy and when we go
and we fully immerse ourselves in the
shoes of another human being as behind
their eyes as much as possible in their
soul we see in this video that there are
five people sleeping in small rooms they
have stereo sets from the 1990s in there
this is these are the places that
desperately need the economic degrees of
freedom opened up and he in the video he
goes on to have moved in to renting a
beautiful larger space and that's
because he's running he's your
production manager for skin as skin yeah
and you have these young women as well
that are that have just as glow to them
from them working and having somewhere
to go work make money come back either
families provide better opportunities
for their kids etc yeah teach us about
this this is it makes me feel so good
yeah yeah it makes me feel really good
too
so you know my simple premise is no one
wants charity no one everybody and I
think that's what we almost forget about
often times from this side of a world I
almost feel like the word dignity most
people it's just I don't know when you
come from places like this the word
dignity has all of its meaning dignity
humans the biggest thing I believe for
humans is dignity you can be poor you
can be but but dignity is it as far as
I'm concerned so with that you you said
dignity and peace when you're raising
your families in your local areas having
those degrees of freedom yes I love
those words that very powerful and those
and you you always have to remember his
words so people want peace and dignity
so for me it is not about so it was very
important is very important actually
quickly the way that in the video you
explained how an organization like Tom's
that comes in and gives a pair of shoes
for every pair of shoes that sold can
actually cause a lot of
unexpected issues this is again this is
like coming in and delivering the water
instead of addressing the root cause
poverty is giving the shoes instead of
teaching people getting the jobs and
opportunity exactly yeah exactly
well you know I mean think about it you
know that's what I try to tell people
because oftentimes you're like what do
you mean we're trying to help we're
turning shoes ok I can't it I know about
your intentions are good trust me I know
I used to buy TOMS shoes as well before
I knew this I know so so I know
intentions are right but um just put you
think about this if you you have noticed
that even when a disaster strikes in
some parts of the United States right
when Houston was whenever an area is
stricken of course we send some help but
have you noticed what people always say
start keep start buying as much as you
can from the local you know from the
local businesses because everybody's
trying to to reboot the economy we know
things have to stop flowing again so in
any way if you come to my village
especially in this village where we are
you know we have 200 something shoemaker
shoemaking small businesses each one of
them hires close to 15 people even do
the math now think about it the daytime
shoe shows that 3000 yeah it's it's it's
it's a few thousand the daytime shoe
shows up with their shoes who can
compete against for you yeah
yeah-hoo-hoo if today your yoga teacher
and somebody somewhere decides because
maybe people can understand that
somebody's some from somewhere sighs oh
gee you know um we're gonna we're gonna
give everybody access to we're gonna
give them free yoga classes how long
before you go out of business yourself
you no longer have a studio because who
can compete against free this one people
need to start thinking about so we we
need business we don't need handouts and
I think it's starting hopefully starting
to get into people's minds but anyway so
that's why what we're trying to do with
skin is skin insofar as we have this
business we basically with jobs are
created back home and I wanted a job it
was more than just for people to be
collecting shea butter shea nut or raw
ingredients because right now that's
what everybody's doing but you see it
makes sense it is almost impossible to
manufacture anything in Africa at least
for small and medium all and
medium-sized businesses why because the
laws are so complicated that the minute
you try to transform anything then it
becomes a nightmare
so most people stay at the level where
they just extract
whether it's shea nut or it is palm oil
whatever it is so that's all we do we
just collect these things we extract and
then we ship it to overseas overseas
gets to process and then they sell it
back to us with a huge premium on it and
in the meantime so the jobs we get are
just like low-level extraction jobs
there is no industries the industry is
in exists almost inexistent and so what
you have is at the very very bottom the
base of a pyramid is all of these
microfinance microfinance recipients and
micro entrepreneurs who are barely
surviving most of them and most of them
will tell you on the gallop there's a
Gallup poll on this showing that an
overwhelming majority of microfinance
recipients given a choice would rather
have a job because we're doing this
because in a way their necessity
entrepreneurs rather than opportunity
entrepreneurs and only ever and so you
have this big bottom of a pyramid
it's micro entrepreneurs surviving
barely surviving and at the top of a
pyramid you have these few
multinationals because we're the only
game in town with jobs actually get to
do whatever the heck they want to people
and then people like oh you see there is
no laws in Africa because the
multinationals get away with everything
they get away with everything not
because we don't have laws actually did
you know what Senegal has the most
protected labor laws in the world but
that's also why we probably have such
high unemployment because no one will
touch an employee in Senegal because you
get involved with an employee you can
never get out of it you're Mary Louise
so anyway so I'll go back to our skin is
skin so skin is skin it's a business
where we manufacture everything in
Africa giving people better jobs with
better pay better security and all of
that and like you
unlike here maybe where people look down
on certain jobs there we are reminded of
a value of a job however simple that job
is we are reminded that I did the day
nothing feels better than waking up in
the morning and going and working making
money at with this the sweat of your
forefront and taking it back home
feeding your family taking care of your
child showing your child a good role
model and you go to bed at night and you
feel good about yourself we have not
lost gratitude for that back home and I
do hope that people here get to reinsure
their jobs because of the very minimum
it's bringing them that so that's what
we do and just so everyone knows what
kind of an entrepreneur well yet is she
goes and she goes through the 45 percent
tariff because normally somebody would
get sorted off by that and say Oh 45
percent tariff no no no no no I'm just
gonna go in the source from somewhere
else where I can only have 5% tariff she
will go and take that in and work with
what is required to to help uplift the
local communities and economies there
was a part in the video as well where
where you were the the local mayor the
local the mayor there was another OVA Co
on the cow on the other a store yeah the
leather goods store they make our bags
they make up now shake your pouches for
skin-to-skin mouse' gooey what's that
gay Moussa gay he he specifically said
that this business has been you know
multi generations and you had every
opportunity to not work with them
because you could get it source
somewhere cheaper but you still chose to
work with them and I think that when
people make decisions like that that's
when their soul lights up towards
helping people instead of towards money
and there's a big difference there's a
big distinction you can see
it and feel it in people when they
behave that yeah so I just wanted to
make sure that people like to find that
you know it's not it's it's it's about
what you find to be most meaningful and
passionate for you in the world but it's
also about bringing people value
bringing them to those degrees of
freedom etc so yes now I want it I want
to see where where else can we only wrap
on this because there's there's you know
skin the skin is going strong you're
speaking you're helping more you're
helping to get other people to
understand that it is that those degrees
of economic freedom and the areas around
the world that so desperately needed to
eradicate poverty and everything else to
get people what they need now what now
what are kind of the next like in our
last bit on the show what are the what
are the next steps that are required for
maximizing the equality of economic
freedom around the world I think this is
the moment at which in my in my process
around all of us and you know it's been
a long journey from this little girl
seven years old who is having this big
question and even what I'm doing today
about it I I i practice as an
entrepreneur my entrepreneurship is my
practice I practice and an I preach so
my thought leadership is when I preach
and then I practice what I preach
through my interpreter being an
entrepreneur now you what you have to
understand is once I finally understood
why some countries are poor and others
are rich I went through a few phases the
first phase was a face of tremendous
relief um and I don't know if movies
talked about that but you know of a girl
who her name is Yahara never heard what
you say I'm sitting home waiting for
husband for her husband otherwise I
would be sitting at home waiting for a
husband member her so her when I
explained all of these to her because
one day I sat down with my whole team
and I explained why I do what I do what
I've discovered along the journey
everything and at the end of me
explaining all of this to her why we
where we are and how we can get out of
it she started crying and I said why are
you crying
she said I'm crying because my whole
life I have to admit
that I have gotten to a point where I
because because my whole life I've seen
us represented as poor pathetic you know
like the world always is to come to our
aid and so I have come to believe that
maybe we are inferior and then she said
but that's not why I'm crying and I said
why are you crying and she said because
now I know that it is not true mmm
so even I when I discovered when I went
down to the root of this and
understanding what's going on why we are
where we are
why are we still where we are because I
when I discovered why has tremendous
sense of relief like her because maybe
even I maybe even if I never admitted
that to myself maybe a part of me
somehow somewhere must have felt that
maybe there was something wrong with me
because that's maybe how a lot of
Africans for you mm-hmm because at some
point it just makes no sense otherwise
and want to if we were the recipients of
all anybody you know shoes would start
to question themselves at some point
yeah and their value and their
capability yes yes that's what it does
so I felt relieved and the type of
relief and also hope an excitement but
can you can feel when you've been going
to 20 million different doctors because
you have maybe this physical illness or
mental illness and none of them could
see what's going on everybody saying we
don't know we don't know or there's
nothing we don't see anything but you
like but I'm feeling it I feel it is
something wrong and then all of a sudden
a diagnostic that makes sense
yeah all the whole come with it cuz you
know if you diagnose it you can maybe do
something about it yes excitement so I
went from being super relieved and now
I'm excited and then I became depressed
and why did I become depressed there's a
lot of work ahead of us I think miss
goes to your question about where do we
go from here I have the Kim D prize
because I'm like what the hell I looked
around me and I'm like how come no one
is talking about this
ramiz are talking about it's actually if
nothing else we seem to have a bias
against it and how come everywhere I go
any stream media were coming after we
are coming after you maybe three media
is not going to be existing anymore they
don't change if they don't reinvent
yourselves because we are to look at
what we're talking about and look at
what the bickering between CNN and Fox
News is talking about they're not
talking about the pressing issues of
enabling people to maximally flourish
with economic degrees of freedom Raul
yeah so I got yeah and and our young
people all over in these universities
are being taught all of these but when
they talk about poverty they mix it up
with all the consequences of poverty
you've ever been taught by TOMS shoes
and everything is gonna get better or
you know give to charity water and
everything is gonna get better don't
take me wrong do not take me wrong I
don't want anybody dying in the meantime
if somebody can get clean water in the
pot in the meantime please we need to do
that but when I have everybody everybody
is working and focused on the short-term
solutions of just taking clean water and
bringing it to me and there's no one
left where I am working which is below
mid to long term solutions we have a
problem so a proposed mid to long term
solution would be create something in
the dorm room that can launch
digitally to Africa that can decrease
the red tape for someone to start it I
mean is going there and you're going
there so but step one so where are we
going from here awareness I need
awareness of the people awareness of the
masses because I know remember when I
told you that I believe in human beings
yeah
but human beings but they cannot do
their best work if they don't know what
the proper diagnosis is so I want them
to get the proper diagnosis I want them
to know what I know today yes because
once they do yeah watch me I love you
because right now you've been telling
them I need clean water and everything
they bring me charity water I need shoes
they bringing me TOMS shoes it's all
super clever stuff but they're bringing
but once and it was
bit more here once the mass is here and
the mass is back home know the story and
know the real diagnosis then watch them
from all sides on the African side on
the western side everybody is gonna get
to do what humans do best it's put their
imagination to work some of them will
come up with a solution
you know government solutions others
with start you know sort of cities
lovers with all types I mean people are
gonna think they're gonna it's it's
gonna be they're gonna think of things
that I haven't even thought about myself
and the world hasn't come up with yet I
love that part about this equation is
that in the next couple of decades that
we can look to Africa for some major
intellectual advancement society that
it's so funny because I think one of the
things that that enables people to do
the major intellectual advancements is
the leap frogging right old
infrastructures so when you can advance
directly to blockchain and
cryptocurrency past the banking systems
completely you can brainstorm and start
creating much faster etcetera so we we
were some energy advancements some
educational advancements the next i
don't level at all levels i think i
believe i believe that once people know
this which is not being told to them all
over the world in africa and outside of
Africa people will be working towards
solutions that are gonna take us to
greater economic freedom yeah in Africa
and in other poor countries around the
world and then and then watch for tide
rise and man poured some sunglasses on
then because it's complete so that's
what's next what is awareness building
that's why I'm here that's why I think
there's so much for this opportunity
I love in fact oh you're brilliant
you're preaching the truth in it I love
having you on the show we'll have you
back in 2019 your husband back to talk
about the schools that he's working on
as well there's a lot to still explore
and to help actualize the potential of
everyone across the world speaking of
those sunglasses I was remembering
watching you in the video going like
this all the time it was a heart it was
a hottest month of the year usually we
have really nice whoever like almost saw
us go ever anyways enough yeah yeah yeah
it's like yeah 40 Celsius something yeah
yes yes yeah um okay I love you all
thank you so much for tuning in everyone
greatly appreciate it
um check out the links in the bio please
go check out it gets work also go and
build the future maximize your potential
and the potential of civilization let's
build together and create remove the
structural violence is together much
love everyone thank you give us your
comments and the in the thumb of your
thoughts in the comments as well and we
will see you soon peace thank you
bye everyone